OVER AND GO AWAY.
THAT IS NOT WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN, IT IS ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE.
>> Tucker: WE ACTIVELY SEEK
OUT PEOPLE WHO WILL TELL THE
TRUTH ON THIS SUBJECT.
THERE AREN'T MANY.
BOB WOODSON IS ONE OF THEM, HE
IS A CIVIL RIGHTS LAWYER AND WE
ARE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM ON THE
SHOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS WHAT IS
HAPPENING, IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR 50 YEARS, IF THERE'S ONE
THING THAT HAS WRECKED THE
COUNTRY, IT IS THIS.
WHY WON'T ANYBODY SAY IT?
>> BECAUSE IT IS NOT POLITICALLY
CORRECT TO SAY THAT BECAUSE THEY
ARE BUYING INTO THE WHOLE RACE
THEORY THAT SOMEHOW THE PROBLEMS
BLACK AMERICA FACES TODAY IS A
LEGACY OF SLAVERY AND JIM CROW
AND IT IS BLATANTLY NOT TRUE.
WE HAD THE WOODSON CENTER HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THIS.
ALANO, WHO WAS A PART OF OUR
GROUP TOO WITH A WONDERFUL
STATEMENT BUT IN FACT, DADS ARE
STEPPING UP AND THEY HAVE BEEN
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
WE SAW THIS IN LOUISIANA WHEN
KIDS WERE FIGHTING IN THEIR
SCHOOLS FOR THREE DAYS AND THEY
WERE ARRESTED.
THESE BLACK DADS DIDN'T GO TO
THE SCHOOL AND DEMAND THAT
TEACHERS RECEIVED EEI TRAINING.
INSTEAD THEY SAID THESE ARE OUR
CHILDREN DESTROYING ONE ANOTHER
AND DESTROYING THEIR FUTURE, WE
HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY AND THE
OBLIGATION TO RESPOND SO FIVE OF
THEM GOT TOGETHER AND WENT INTO
THE SCHOOL AND AS SOON EXPANDED
TO 40 MEN AND THESE DADS ARE
PATROLLING THE SCHOOLS, GOING TO
CLASSES.
THEY WORK WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DADS WERE SCREENED
GOING IN.
IT'S PART OF A MOVEMENT THAT HAS
BEEN GOING ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS THAT THE WOODSON CENTER
HAS SUPPORTED GROUPS LIKE THIS.
IN FACT, WE SPENT ABOUT $500,000
GIVING $500,000 GRANTS TO
GRASSROOTS GROUP LIKE THIS GROUP
IN THE COUNTRY.
I AM JUST PLEASED THEY ARE
GETTING THE KIND OF PUBLIC
RECOGNITION THAT THEY NEED AND
WHAT THEY NEED ISN'T MORE
AWARDS, THEY NEEDED REWARDS.
WE NEED TO SHIFT SOME OF THE
MONEY THAT IS BEING WASTED BY
CORPORATIONS ON
BLACK LIVES MATTER AND SPEND THE
MONEY INSIDE THESE COMMUNITIES.
THE SOLUTIONS ARE WHERE THE
PROBLEMS ARE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
IF YOU ASK ANY SUCCESSFUL, WELL
ADJUSTED, PRODUCTIVE MAN IN THIS
COUNTRY, WHAT IS THE SECRET TO
YOUR HAPPINESS?
MOST OF THEM WILL SAY MY DAD HAD
A LOT TO DO WITH IT.
THAT IS TRUE, MOST OF US WOULD
SAY THAT IS TRUE, I CAN'T
BELIEVE WE ARE IGNORING THIS BUT
WE ARE, I AM NOT SURE WHY.
>> BECAUSE IT IS NOT POLITICALLY
CORRECT.
I THINK THE RADICAL LEFT HAS
BEEN USING BLACK AMERICA AS A
POLITICAL TOOL AND THEY ARE
EXPLOITING THE WHOLE RACE ISSUE
FOR THEIR OWN GAIN, AND SO THE
ONLY WAY THAT IS GOING TO CHANGE
AND BE CHALLENGED AS TO ALLOW
BLACK AMERICA TO SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES AND THAT IS WHAT THE
WOODSON CENTER IS DOING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE EXPANDING ON
THE PROGRAM AND WE HOPE TO GO
OUT AND REACH OTHERS TO CONVINCE
THEM THAT WE NEED TO INVEST IN
THESE DADS.
THEY RECOGNIZE THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO BE SURROGATE FATHERS
TO HUNDREDS OF OTHER CHILDREN,
AND SO WE HOPE AND PRAY THAT THE
COUNTRY WILL WAKE UP, INSTEAD OF
SEEING GEORGE SOROS SPANNED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN A TEXAS
TOWN TO PROMOTE DEFUND THE
POLICE, WE NEED TO INVEST
INSTEAD ON THESE GRASSROOTS --
WHITE AMERICA CAN'T DO A THING
TO SOLVE THE PROBLEMS OF BLACK
AMERICA.
MAKING WHITE PEOPLE LESS RACIST
DOESN'T MAKE BLACK PEOPLE MUCH
SAFER.
THEY HAVE TO BE THEIR OWN UPLIFT
OR IS.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
THAT IS